[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
we're coming to the end of the first
quarter with the rhinos in the red zone
for the first time
got to say bill i like watching these
rhinos ransom takes the snap drops back
with good protection and that's a
completed pass to a very wide-open
hingle mccrinkleberry the rookie out of
penn state nice ground i'm buying a
cringle bear you think he's happy
oh boy he is loving it down there oh we
got something of a shooting gallery oh
yeah look at that boy that is something
and
oh oh wait we got a flag though you got
that for excessive celebration yeah
well i see and i'm not sure about that
called i don't know bill that was three
pumps and the rule book says you cannot
have more than two
oh my gosh but look at the kid he's
pleading his case with the referee
pleading his case
yeah clearly three pups coast johnson
definitely not happy about this call
five minutes into the fourth quarter
third and ten the rhinos again
threatening to score can the cougars
hold them big play coming here bill
ransom takes the snap drops back he
floats one into the end zone and
mcringleberry pulls it down oh he's got
it
oh my gosh for his second touchdown of
the day for this rookie he has got to be
feeling great about himself
i'll tell you man he's uh oh see now
there's two pumps
yeah he's really testing the boundaries
and he's clearly gotten the refs
attention here
a third pump will draw a flag no matter
what see oh he just did it again
what did now what is that the second
time now you have to flag him on it yeah
he had to you know bill it's just
frustrating seeing young players without
the ability to restrain themselves oh it
really is
it's hard i mean the ref's gonna get you
every time yeah
yeah absolutely uh see now the ref
agrees that's three pumps right there
[Applause]
and the quarterback ransom under center
last five minutes of the game
rhinos are marching here again hard to
stop this team from scoring bill they
have so many weapons
ransom takes the snap and it's a shovel
past the mcringleberry ooh he's at the
10.
he's at the five and touchdown rhino oh
my
great block by hardunka chut and that's
gonna be tough for the cougars to come
back from boy what a career day from
henkel mccrinkleberry the rookie out of
penn state
oh he was just amazingly fired up here
today john you gotta love the way this
guy plays and he
oh oh see now there's one pump oh
well i cannot believe this kid you got
to put your team first in situations
like this and the kringleberry's just
not doing it no there's two
jeff now if he pumps a third time he
will draw his third penalty for today
everybody here waiting with betty breath
he did oh did he yes he did it oh that
just couldn't help himself amazing i
mean
come on in professional football it's
really changed yeah that's what it is
yes you can argue all you want but
flag well it's been thrown that's right
if it's three pumps the ref's not gonna
take it away now not
duration and intensity doesn't make any
difference jeff let's have a look at the
replay here to see if indeed he did do
the three pumps
all right no question there is the first
one yeah right
agreed and then coming up is the second
one
okay yes very clear it's the third we'll
see it it's coming out you're here
oh yeah you're right there's absolutely
three pumps there
oh uh apologies to all those watching
with young children uh clearly
unintentional
i am here with osman says buckshank the
rookie out of stanford university
who is undoubtedly the mvp of today's
game
with an interception that he runs back
for a touchdown in the last 30 seconds
of the contest
osmotes can you walk us through what
happened on that last play it was
amazing yeah we knew we had to go out
there
give a hundred percent we executed it
just went our way today
and was the quarterback giving you any
clues uh today oz uh
it looked like you knew that ball was
gonna be there what was happening knew
we wanted to have some fun you know
execute
play one quarter at a time give a
hundred percent i'm saying
okay okay you know let's just let's talk
about last week's game
uh uh you guys lost a heartbreaker give
me your state of mind
then versus now i wanted to do
play-by-play give it a 100
execution-wise execute okay
i'm going to ask you something
completely different that's not about
football look at me oz just look at me
for a second i'm going to ask you a
question
right here got it boy so you and your
wife recently had
right here stay with me you and your
wife recently had twins okay how does it
feel to be a new dad
you know we wanted to stay as a team
execute give a hundred percent
play by play okay you know what i'm
gonna just i'm just gonna
i'm gonna do a little test right now uh
hey oz how'd you get to the game today
they're a good team great team 100 yep
and what'd you have for dinner last
night 100 100 yeah you're dead of course
100
or whatever 100 was you know what
can you just do me a favor and tell me
one specific thing like just one
actual original observation that you had
about today's game the game that you won
almost single-handedly do you think that
you could do that oz
oh 100 oh god damn it okay we are now
going live to a breaking press
conference where seattle cornerback
richard sherman has something to say
first off i would like to say thank you
to everybody who
came out tonight i appreciate you
getting up and coming here
at this late hour um there's some things
that need to be said
some issues i'd like to talk about that
are non-football related
and without any further ado i'm just
gonna get to it
how you gonna tell me the lego movie is
not gonna get nominated for one
of the best animated films of the year
inconceivable okay
huge box office success
critical consensus everybody gave it an
a i mean hey
this is the one movie if they could have
done it they would have given this
106 on rotten tomatoes
okay nobody didn't like the lego movie
i don't care if you're two or 92. so
you're telling me that this movie
is not one of the five best animated
films of the year
but how are you gonna nominate selma for
best film and ava duvernay not gonna get
a director nomination like i don't
understand
exactly how that works i'm not a member
of the academy but it seems like things
are a little backwards there wouldn't
you agree marshawn
hibiscus engraving furthermore
how y'all gonna give bennett miller a
best director nomination but then you're
not gonna nominate the film
fox catcher okay which he directed which
was good
he was masterful in his job it's just i
don't you know
what's going on like it's like what's
the logic there you don't mean to be
that good of a job well come to film is
that nominated for academy award
biscuits and gravy
you get to nominate 10 films every year
but this year you decide you're only
going to nominate eight films
if you got the space to do it and you
all like fox catcher so much that you're
gonna give the director a director
nomination
then why would you not nominate the film
same goes for ava duvernay
you already made selma a film that you
want to win the award
but then you're not going to let her get
her due or her accolades
it's just something seems off here
something seems off
[Music]
hibiscus bravery
thank you so much i'm sorry just that we
needed to get that off of my chest
all right and now marshawn has something
very important that he needs to say
that's very close to his heart
marshawn
biscuits and gravy no no no something
really real that he want to say
with full sentences
there was a biscuit with some gravy no
no go on marshall
speak your mind marshawn lynch
[Music]
i just think that the producers of enter
the woods did themselves a disservice
by not including the narrator from the
original
musical theater production boom
as in legion of
but that's on you that's on y'all
biscuits and gravy
we're not taking any questions thank you
very much go hawks
say he could have been the greatest
player on his team
or perhaps the greatest player of his
generation
perhaps he could have been the greatest
player of
all time
[Music]
if only he didn't run in slow motion
[Applause]
that's right y'all cause you know what
we only get
one chance let's leave it all
on the field today we're gonna
give them something they can remember
yeah
yeah let's do
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's time to handle our business
is
we also know we're the best that ever
this is our time this is our moment
we can't let nobody take this away from
us
we got to do
[Applause]
you know i got your backyard i know
y'all got mine
we're taking this all the way to the
super bowl y'all
this is our destiny
let's keep doing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
can nobody stop us
we can do anything we set our minds to
[Music]
uh
play this game like it's the last game
of your life
[Music]
uh